Star Trek and Star Wars are often looked
upon as two sides of the same Syfy coin
locked in a never-ending battle of
philosophy versus action that will last
until the end of time or at least until
the arguing nerds
need a nap in truth both franchises
probably owe their continued existence
to each other
George Lucas admitted that Star Trek
basically paved the way for Star Wars
and William Shatner conceded that
paramount only became interested in
giving Star Trek a real shot on the big
screen after Star Wars took the world by
storm in 1977 generally fans pledge
outright allegiance to one franchise
over the other but that's an idea that
the following actives chose to ignore
entirely here are a few actors who
visited both a galaxy far far away and
the Alpha Quadrant George Takei Star
Trek legend George Takei has been part
of the enterprise from the very
beginning first appearing as lieutenant
Sulu in the original series and going on
to reprise the role for six Star Trek
feature films video games and even an
episode of Voyager but like many Star
Trek alumni it was through voice work
that he made the transition between the
two biggest universes in sci-fi Takei
became the most high-profile name to
take the leap when he landed the path of
general lock dirt in the Clone Wars
animated series I congratulate you on
your good thought when asked about
appearing in Star Wars it's a ke remarks
but he didn't consider it to be jumping
ship telling the Comic Book Resources
the Star Trek philosophy is to embrace
the diversity of life and Star Wars with
a part of that diversity Star Trek is
science fiction and Star Wars has more
science fantasy but with the episodes of
Star Wars the Clone Wars where they
worked on I think there is emerging
their Star Trek and Star Wars living
together in harmony
brent Spiner another legend of Trek
brent Spiner run as Lieutenant Commander
data spend 15 years that includes the
seven seasons of the next generation and
for feature films one of which earned
him a Saturn Award for Best Supporting
Actor
he also played a data's brother data's
creator and even made an appearance in
the prequel series enterprise as data's
great-great-grandfather so his place in
Trek spans more than just one series
Spiner eventually put trek behind him
that's one point he even publicly took
issue with fans perception of the show
saying in 2011 we carry guns it's a joke
it's like that illusion that it has
somehow all about peace it's really not
after provoking the wrath of Trekkies
everywhere Spiner subsequent casting in
Star Wars rebels must have struck a
nerve the actor voice to Senator Gold
Travis a character who coincidentally is
a total traitor
no kidding Brent
Ethan Phillips though he pops up in
everything from girls to veep to
homeboys and outs of space Ethan
Phillips most memorable role remains
Neelix the USS Voyager chef and
Ambassador Phillips portrayed the
talaxian for the show's entire 7 season
run but he also made three minor
appearances as different Star Trek
characters in next generation and
enterprise Phillips played two different
Ferengi and he also made a cameo
appearance in Star Trek first contacts
as a holographic Metro D Phillips has
since become something of a regular in
the world of star wars video games
providing the voice of transport pilot
Hammond flat in force commander
he also played an imperial medical droid
20 and governor and royal Grenada
trooper in 2002 Scholastic battlegrounds
as well as several additional characters
in 2003 Knights of the Old Republic
oh hello to you you're new to the
Academy aren't you Simon Pegg British
actor Simon Pegg is known for many roles
from his zombie fighting hero and Shaun
of the Dead to his recurring role in the
Mission Impossible film franchise but
Trek fans know him as Montgomery Scott
in JJ Abrams Star Trek reboot movies he
proves to be such an asset to Abrams
that the director later admitted he had
an ulterior motive when he cast him in
the minor role of unkar plutt in Star
Wars The Force awakens saying when we
were shooting the force awakens in Abu
Dhabi he was there as an actor but for
me he was there as a writer and
filmmaker and someone to go around the
issues I was having at the time with the
story and to get some great feedback it
probably didn't take much for Evans to
convince Pegg to appear in the film
either Star Wars I burned the soul pegs
input didn't end there either
he was also sought out by paramount
bosses when Abrams left the Star Trek
franchise bringing Pegg on board as a
co-writer for the third instalment Star
Trek beyond Ron Perlman best known for
playing the demonic antihero Hellboy as
well as the starring role on sons of
anarchy and a few hundred voice roles
Ron Perlman has been around the block
more than one
many of Pullman's hundreds of credits
lie in genre films an area of cinema
he's always supported so when the
opportunity came along to join the cast
of 2002 Star Trek nemesis as the riemann
viceroy Pearlman asked his manager for
the time and place while he enjoyed
working on the movie
neither audiences nor critics seem to
share his enthusiasm fortunately his
foray into Star Wars received a much
more positive reaction Pearlman poised
to garner a Transocean scavenger who
meets his untimely end at the hands of
General Grievous and the highly
acclaimed first season of the Clone Wars
Ed Begley Jr veteran actor and
environmentalist at Begley Jr it's
probably best known for its seven-year
stint on st. elsewhere though he
actually has hundreds of TV and movie
credits to his name among them eyes
apparent from the Star Trek Voyager
two-parter futures end in which he took
on the one-off role of 20th century
industrialist Henry Starling who just
happens to be working with a character
played by Sarah Silverman Begley Jr has
since said he felt really blessed to be
a part of the Star Trek franchise as a
huge fan of the show though that didn't
stop him from taking a gig with the
rival franchise the very same year he
was hired to provide the voice of Boba
Fett in the radio adaptation of Return
of the Jedi produced with the blessing
of George Lucas and speaking of Boba
Fett jason wingreen
a victim of the dreaded Star Wars DVD
editions jason wingreen saw his past as
the voice of Boba Fett in the Empire
Strikes Back
chopped under a place with the voice of
Tamara Morrison the man who played Jango
Fett in the prequel trilogy to add
insult to injury when Green was never
actually credited for his contribution
to the Star Wars universe which only
became common knowledge four years after
the greatly mastering of o4 while he may
be best remembered as Harry Snowden from
all in the family for Star Trek fans
he'll always be dr. link' the federation
scientists who gets sent to the
uninhabited planet menara su to conduct
studies in original series episode the
impact deep boy the diminutive deeper
Roy has an impressive filmography
stretching back about 40 years including
two big-screen Star Wars installments
Roy play
musician droopy McCall in Return of the
Jedi a member of the max rebo band the
12 piece ensemble that performed in
Jabba the Hutt's Tatooine palace the 4
foot three actor actually appeared and
credited in the Empire Strikes Back
as a body double for Yoda during a
number of scenes on Dagobah Roy is also
one of the very few actors to appear on
screen in both franchises playing
Scotty's oyster face alien sidekick keen
sir in the rebooted Trek series keen sir
was never even meant to join Scotty on
the franchise's most famous starship but
Roy's performance was so memorable that
they invited him back to reprise his
role clancy brown sci-fi fans shouldn't
really need an introduction to clancy
brown he's played the immortal
antagonistic Ergon in Highlander and
Sergeant them in Starship Troopers even
your kids know Clancy Brown if only in
voice donate to the Children's Fund why
would it children every dent firmly
despite an impressive sci-fi resume it
wasn't until 2002 that Brown showed up
on Star Trek taking on the role of
sobral and the enterprise episode desert
crossing in it Archer and sucker accept
an invitation to his homeworld and then
wittingly find themselves caught up in a
war among his countless voice roles
Brown also dipped into Star Wars
territory when he played Darth Maul's
brother Savage Opress and the Clone Wars
series as well as Ryder Azadi in rebels
who only kind of looks exactly like him
clive rebel renowned stage actor Clive
Ravel portrayed a tweaked version of
classic English character Sir Guy of
Gisbourne in 1991 next generation
episode Cupid which took the crew to the
12th century world of Robin Hood well
this wasn't the most memorable
performance for New Zealand native have
given over the course of his
distinguished career at least it wasn't
replaced in later edits like his work on
the original Star Wars trilogy was
[Music]
sorry rebel supplied the voice of
emperor palpatine in the first cut of
the Empire Strikes Back birth like so
many others his work was dubbed over for
the 2004 DVD release replaced with the
voice of Ian McDermott who took over as
the Emperor with Return of the Jedi
rebel was humble about the change
however conceding that continuity was
important and saying that the filmmakers
made a good choice with McDermott
considering that the original 1980
Emperor was played by a woman with
superimposed chimp eyes pretty much
anything was an improvement greg
grunberg as a self-proclaimed geek greg
grunberg
couldn't have asked for a better friend
than a man who rebooted Star Trek and
kick-started a third Star Wars trilogy
gran burgers works with JJ Abrams almost
exclusively so when Abrams began his
cinematic reinvention of Star Trek he
called on Gomberg again trusting his
friend to overdub the dialogue for James
Kirk stepdad here you add your mind that
carbonate get away with this just as
your mother's off planet you get your
ass back home now he appeared in person
as commander Finnegan in 2016 Star Trek
beyond though by that point he had
already crossed a franchise divide
Romberg played resistance pilots now for
Wesley in 2015 supports awakens though
he later told Star Trek comm that he's
on the fence about which franchise is
his favorite Olivia Dabo best known to
Trekkies of Starfleet Academy intern
Amanda Rogers from the next generation
episode true cue Olivia double Darbo is
probably best known for playing Kevin
Arnold Tippi sister Karen in The Wonder
Years believe it or not Dabo considers
herself to be a pretty big sci-fi nerd
telling the official Star Trek website I
considered it a real honor to be working
on the continuation of the Star Trek a
legacy I'd grown up with it had a huge
effect on my childhood and not unlike
Star Wars it made me more curious about
space other life-forms in our galaxy and
the wonder of astronomy in general in
2008 she joined a number of her former
Star Trek colleagues at Lucasfilm to
record the voice of Luminara and Julie
for the Clone Wars animated series and
oh yeah patty Maloney emerging from the
darkest day in Star Wars history it's
patty Maloney who played a part in the
infamous and totally bizarre Star Wars
Holiday Special
the three foot eleven actress was hired
to play two specials main character
Chewbacca son lump owaru better known as
lumpy
no seriously Melones memories of the
especially weird program were completely
positive saying we were all very pleased
with the outcome of it actually I was I
was very pleased with it a special aired
in 1978 and because of the sheer shame
involved was never seen again in any
official capacity Melones role in Star
Trek was another one created for a
person of her stature in the 1996
Voyager episode the Thor she plays one
of the many creations of the clown a
manifestation of fear born of a linked
neural network because you know Wi-Fi
this time she's credited as only little
woman which is still a huge improvement
over being a grunting idiot named lumpy
added bonus it was even a speaking role
oh boy and you got to hang out with
Michael McKean point
Star Trek okay we're taking that point
back thanks for watching click the loop
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know your loved thing
[Music]